here's a deacon what guests had to say
after the show all right we're back with
the younger more casual but I feel like
throwing a football on the walnut
Hyannis portrait okay here's a great
softball for you John why do you contend
that the 2012 election was the most
consequent consequential in recent
history because the Republicans were
rolling back the American social
contract even Paul Ryan said that he
wanted to rewrite that which would have
meant returning us or at least trying to
return us to a pre New Deal era you know
they don't believe in this stuff Paul
Ryan was an an rant is an an Rand guy
right and and that philosophy would have
gone to the center of our politics we
would have been moved very very sharply
to the right and worse here's the worst
part the economy's headed up a little
bit right now if that if Romney had won
it would have seemed that slashing taxes
for the wealthy slashing regulation
slashing programs for the poor had a
cause and effect on an improving economy
and progressive policies would have been
discredited for a generation I was here
progressive what does he mention see
what has he done since he was regencies
approaches we're talking about Obamacare
progressives tried for 100 years since
the Progressive Party platform of 1912
with Theodore Roosevelt to get universal
coverage several presidents tried they
all failed until Barack Obama intint the
progressives were the public option and
he didn't do well that's that's making
the perfect the enemy of the good you
didn't get everything you wanted
Roosevelt didn't get everything you
wanted me interested sure but he should
have heat it but he should have went for
the public option no that's it little
dress a few hats the Minda look I was
all for the public option I have a
single-payer the public was for it the
poor until they didn't back it no the
politic a they gave analytics is what
you can get through and you know what
presidents had failed John to do this he
got it done so it's pretty great a
second best strategy not and I give him
all the credit world but let's get clear
on where the where the goal posts are
the left-wing approach would be
single-payer you know like with all the
other
modern countries that's what I want the
the right-wing approach would just keep
going along the way we're doing yeah
45,000 people dying every year because
they don't have it the middle approach
should have been the public option it's
not that radical the 70% of people were
Ford until the Republicans I was has
Republicans don't run away from polls
they change them the Democrats run away
from them here's here's the problem in
2009-2010 they were trying to get this
bill through the crazy Senate Finance
Committee
yeah the way November the holiday gang
of was it if they did the public option
thing it would it wouldn't go I wish
there was a goodies did an option
there's no other [ __ ] I'm gonna be
great if they they should do me I'll
show the gun in the shirt under the
shirt you know like David yeah yeah
there's a lot of other progressive
legislation too especially in the first
two years that got done all right let me
that's question for Neal if our economy
is really black black back neela for our
economy is really black why aren't
companies hiring and when they do why
our wage is still so low fewer an
employer especially if you're a small
mid-sized business the incentive to hire
is not particularly great partly because
of the regulations if you look at small
businesses the burden of regulation is
relatively much higher on them than it
is on large businesses and although you
can see the economy recovering there's
great uncertainty about future
regulation a lot of small businesses
don't really know what Obamacare is
going to mean for them and there's a lot
of uncertainty also about future path of
Taxation so even the firm's that could
expand that have the cash to hire are
not doing it and if you look at the
survey data it's clear that it's not
because there wasn't enough stimulus
it's certainly not because interest
rates aren't low enough because they
couldn't be lower it's because there's a
sense that the future is uncertain and
they really don't know whether the
policy environment is going to encourage
we're interest rates are going up a
little now right
well that that possibility was
internally or even that possibility
which is not certain at all but even the
discussion of that possibility caused
the markets to go into frenzy and by the
way when you talk about the progressive
aspects of the Obama presidency
his biggest economic success has been to
bring the stock market back to where it
was before the crisis who both threw
benefits from that the 1% not not the
80% right who hardly owned any stocks
thank you back Romney and it hasn't that
austerity policy in Europe and here
basically failed can we agree on that
one of the interesting things about this
debate is that it's become so simplified
into a caricature austerity and a
caricature stimulus as if there were
options to do more than a 10% deficit
attempts out of GDP deficit the stimulus
was pretty big for three years the
deficit was around about nine or ten
percent and the austerity which was
being discussed I don't think I remember
anybody saying we should be balancing
the budget in 2009 so we should get away
from a carrot party freshmen we're
saying that in 2011 that nobody Syrian
dowry buddies know that serious note I
think if we can talk and broad strokes
I think England I know and I am sure
other European countries did go for
austerity they didn't have a choice bill
I mean honestly the debt burden was so
much higher you know the public plus
private debt for the UK is like five
hundred percent of GDP maybe true so
there wasn't a choice the idea that
Britain could have done Keynesian
stimulus which is kind of Paul Krugman's
fantasy isn't credible it wasn't an
option even if the Labour Party had
somehow won in 2010 they wouldn't have
been able to do it the southern
Europeans didn't have that option the
markets essentially said we're not
lending you any more money
you guys are bust so we have to be
realistic about what the alternatives
were and they were very very limited
especially within the euro zone okay
monetary policy was made by the Germans
alright question for Patrick do you see
mental illness as a significant factor
in gun violence so we need a rule
governing mental health to be fully
covered because what's going to happen
is if it's excluded like it has in the
past people like these folks who we find
out more about Santa Monica or Jared
Lochner or everywhere else there are
people who are not getting mental health
care so if we want to do something to
really try to make a difference in
minimizing these tragedies let's not
turn our backs on people who have a
mental illness and that's exactly how we
deal with this issue today and what
sanctioned is that now insurance
companies because they know no one cares
about people with mental illness can
literally do
criminate and get away with it because
no one's saying oh you should have
covered that person because no one wants
to treat these illnesses the same as
every other physical Eisenhower got
remember reading about how Eisenhower
got education money through as defense
you know at the height of the Cold War
couldn't you get more mental health
funding through as part of a gun package
guns well you hit the nail ahead
Jonathan but I think it's better
organized
we have met well you're gonna try again
they're gonna come back you know but
that's a really will be the last place
it would go through no no you you
sweeten it because a lot of the
Republicans who were against you know
background checks and that kind of thing
after Newtown they said but we're all
for mental you know doing something
about mental health in that two-second
period
I think the veteran s - they are busy
because the veterans bring Republicans
and Democrats together and veterans had
this quote signature one of the war
which is both traumatic brain injury
post-traumatic stress I think the way to
approach mental health is get something
that everyone can sign on and the way
we're treating our veterans is
deplorable deploy
such a naughty issue because how do you
commit somebody we're all a little crazy
but but like when I see that that
mugshot of the Newtown killer that you
know that look I mean I know this is
wrong but I think put that guy away just
on the picture so except that bill it
could be the Joker costume the guy in
Arizona and you know urn and Colorado
suite so many of these people have
problems well before they got their
snapshot in their picture and what if it
were cancer anything else you treat them
on first indication right I guess you
can tell I get skin cancer so I go to
the doctor and get skin cancer checkups
you these days probably are worthy of a
prostate check because you're
that's what I get for defending my honor
all right thank you very much Real Time
with Bill Maher Friday night at 10:00
ask Bill and his guests who are
questions right after the show at
hbo.com